au cinéma les yeux d'elsa de
saint-cyr-l'ecole ce week-end ce sera la
clôture de la 9ème édition du festival
les yeux pleins d'étoilés on vous attend
nombreux évidemment avec plein de films
et de nombreuses surprises et surtout un
film qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur cyrano de bergerac qu'on vous
présentera le vendredi 28 juin à 20h30
séance unique accompagné par mois je
vous ferais je me ferai un plaisir de
vous expliquer pourquoi c'est un grand
film
alors évidemment gérard depardieu son
prix d'interprétation à cannes en 90 ce
grand texte de mon rostand une histoire
vraiment formidable nouvelle histoire
d'amour
un grand moment à vivre en famille à
partir de 10 ans ça sera des souvenirs
pour toute la vie et nous continuerons
dimanche 30 juin à 10 heures avec une
séance très spéciale d'un ciné conte
dans le ciel c'est une création
originale des yeux d'elsa en partenariat
avec versailles grand parc
c'est une séance gratuite alors le
principe est simple c'est un spectacle
hybride entre film il y aura la
projection de quatre films et spectacles
vivants puisque une conteuse charles
gillot interviendra entre les films et
fera de ce spectacle un moment magique
puisque elle lira en fait les histoires
et on va vivre avec elle les aventures
de stella l'étoile qu'elle incarne dans
sa quête initiatique ce sera donc le
dimanche 30 juin à 10 heures au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa à partir de 3 ans et
c'est une séance gratuite
[Musique]